I mentioned this the other night we
learned that a talk-show in China has
been completely ripping off our shows
opening the show is called da Peng we
are not making this up take a look this
is real a side-by-side comparison of our
show opening and da peng's
show opening absolutely real so we saw
that we were shocked and so we started
talking about it on the air we we called
them out as a result they changed their
opening they heard about what we were
saying in China they heard about our
protest and they started using a sad new
opening this is the opening I'm not this
is really what they're using now look at
this it's really sad I know they clearly
[Music]
that's the saddest thing I've ever seen
no that that really bummed me out when I
saw an apple Dapeng also issued an
apology take a look
dr. Lee watching technology mobile Sean
Cunningham eg GTM ago trisha hershberger
that's alright and then he ended his
apology with a sorry dance well here's
the thing yeah I mean first of all I
don't know how yeah I hang if you're
watching I now feel bad that I made you
feel bad he seems like a nice guy and
you know I know I'm sorry I brought the
whole thing up we were just looking to
fill time exactly
that's all wherever to me
we thought we could killed in the minute
or so yeah it's up and you didn't have
to apologize and you didn't have to stop
using our opening you know you're just a
small online talk show in China and
frankly I was flattered that you ripped
us off I took it as a compliment so to
make things good because I want to make
things right I decided to have our
graphics department create an entirely
new opening just for your show I'm
serious you can use this it's made by
our great graphic artist here it's now
your show opening if you want it take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
actually
to have that also hang to emphasize just
how sorry we are here's our there was no
need to apologize sorry for making you
feel bad dance
[Applause]
clearly we clearly we put no effort into
this this